سقط الصاروخ الاوكرانيه في الاراضي
البولنديه بالخطا وانهالت الانتقادات على
القياده الاوكرانيه وعلى الرئيس فولدون
ارزنسكي بسرعه الصاروخ او اكثر الرئيس
الاوكراني اصر على تحميل روسيا المسؤوليه
رغم تاكيد وارسو والنيتو ان الصاروخ
اوكراني اوكراني شارد مع الاصرار على ان
المسؤوليه الاساسيه تبقى على روسيا التي
امطرت ولا تزال تمطر السماء جارتها
الغربيه بالصواريخ
فتح عليه باب الاتهامات خاصه على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي فكثيرون راوا انه يحاول
جر نيته والعالم لحرب العالميه الثالثه
متهمين الرئيس واركان قيادته بالكذب وهو
اتهام قريب له الروس كثيره
كرتون
[موسيقى]
ولي العهد
الاعلام
[موسيقى]
الامريكي
السابق الى البيت الابيض كتب الترامبل ابن
على تويتر قائله انه بما ان صاروخ
اوكرانيا هو الذي اصاب بولندا وهي حلفتنا
فيتو فهل يمكننا على الاقل التوقف عن
انفاق المليارات لتصليحهم الان هو تساؤل
ليس بريئا ذلك الذي اطلقه ترامبل ابن اذن
لكن الاصرار الاوكراني على تحميل
المسؤوليه لروسيا ربما تكون الاجابه عليه
في دخول الشتاء وفي ظهور مؤشرات على تراجع
الدعم الغربي لكن رسميا لا شيء معلنا حتى
الان ولا مؤشرات على تراجع هذا الدعم
اطلاقا بل انها تنتجون كاد استمرار
المساعده خرج الوزير لويد اوستن ليعدد
مزايا انظمه الدفاع الجوي لسامز التي كانت
اوكرانيا من التصدي لاغلبيه الصواريخ
الروسيه
[موسيقى]
سبب اخر لقلق زينسكي وهو خريطه سيطره
الميدانيه التي تتغير بشكل شبه يومي منذ
انسحاب روسيا من خرسان وهنا يتوقع محللون
عسكريون نقاطا ساخنه جديده واشتداد القتال
في الشرق وبتجاه مدن بحر ازوف في الجنوب
من المرجح ان تكون النقاط الساخن التاليه
بالقرب من دنيا في منطقه دومباس الشرقيه
ولا سيما بالقرب من مدينتي ضخموت وافديه
وفي الجنوب في طريقهم الى مدينه بول
وماريوبل الاستراتيجيتين يشير محللون الى
انه من المرجح ان تجدد روسيا تركيزها على
الشرق بعد انسحابها في الجنوب وسيكون
كتحولا في استراتيجيات الكراملين بعد ان
اعلنت موسكو عن مرحله جديده من الحرب تهدف
الى التحرير الكامل لمن تقدم بصم يقرا
محللون انسحاب روسيا من خيرسون بانه قد
يصب في مصلحه الكاملين الذي يسمح لروسيا
بنقل الموارد بعيدا عن الجنوب وتعزيز
قواتها على طول الخط خط الجبهه الشرقيه
ووافقه معلومات
نقالتهايمز فانما يصل الى 50% من القوات
الروسيه المنسحبه من خرسان يمكن نقلها الى
جبهات اخرى لا سيامه في دوم بس حيث اقامت
موسكو مواقع دفاعيه جديده مهمه ايضا قد
يصبروا كيف قد يجبرها على اعاده توجيه
القوات نحو الجنوب او من الجنوب واعاده
نشر قوات اضافيه في دوناتسك كي لا تسمح
للرؤوس بالتقدم
الاهم ان تحاول اوكرانيا نشر قواتها في
هجوم بري جديد محتمل بين الجبهتين الشرقيه
والجنوبيه خاصه وان استغلال عنصر المفاجاه
كان حاسما سابقا ووصفه خبراء بانه كان
تكتيكان ذكيا للغايه
[موسيقى]
في كل الاحوال ومع اجواء الطقس غير
المواتيه غرد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
تعمل مع حلفاء دوليين لبناء نظام الدفاع
الجوي متكامل ومنسق لان حمايه السماء
الاوكرانيه اولويه تعهدت كندا من جهتها
بان تكون في طليعه الداعمين واعلن رئيس
وزراءها جاستن بيدو تقديم 500 مليون دولار
كمساعده عسكريه وهو في الوقت ذاته فرض
عقوبات على ما يقرب من 20 كيانا روسيا اما
واشنطن في يبدو انها تقرا القصف الروسي
المكثف كما يجب رئيس هيئه الاركان
الجنراللي اعتبر ان الهجمات على البنا
التحتيه تشكل جرائم حرب وحمله ارهابيه بعد
خساره موسكو على كل الجبهات مالي اضاف ان
روسيا تختار استغلال وقتها في محاوله
اعاده تنظيم صفوفها وتفرد حمله من
المعاناه
القصوى على سكان المدنيين الاوكرانيين
بهدف هزيمه الروح المعنويه الاوكرانيه
قبيل الشتا